today's topic big Edie everyone's been
asking us to watch this shake it out
perfect okay let's go hello stop it oh
my god oh ouch
nice I'm Edie I'm 54 years old
[Laughter]
yeah his face is big in people know me
as Big Ed I'm from San Diego California
and I am a professional photographer oh
my god right there right there beautiful
that's perfect oh my god nice nice I
actually gave myself the name Big Ed
this guy seems so creepy right off the
top this is just me
satis fault no job do photography feels
like the best place to be creepy mm-hmm
there's an increase ivory and you could
tell them what to do and they're already
telling you and they're changing clothes
for you you get them and racy for how
many stories have we heard of you know
photographers being very weinstein II
[Music]
after I see that the first ride is so
where's this gonna where is this gonna
appear oh it's just for me it makes me
feel tall
that's the money nice also it's funny
because I'm not tall okay that's not
funny
we're gonna make you less funny and look
I get it I know everyone made fun of him
for not having a neck I'm not gonna do
that
because it could be part of some kind of
mental I just dislike making fun of
people for how they look unless it's
their choice you know I'm saying
that's not his choice it's not as fun no
I'm not gonna get mad him for that my
track record with relationships is not
very good
I was married for two years and it
didn't work out because I was unfaithful
I was not about the lab but you pause
there
that's no father that's your fault it's
all your fault I was good I was good
that I saw your face you could roll the
clip back I didn't laugh
you made me laugh all you it was just a
stupid mistake but I did get a beautiful
daughter out of that marriage Tiffany
she's 29 years old after my divorce I
didn't think about having a girlfriend
because of my daughter my daughter was
my life
Teddy Syd say your doggy prayers okay
okay good job good boy
bye waiting to date so long I said to
myself I'm never gonna find love it's me
and Teddy this is gonna be my life she's
texting me right now
telling me that she loves me but when I
met rose everything changed my
girlfriend is Rose Marie she's 23 years
old and she lives in the Philippines one
time I was doing a comedy show mm-my
Rosa yeah well my black people at and
this Asian guy over to that other thing
hey cuz
I'm Filipino I was after they were the
Negroes of the Asian community
I was not aware of this one yes they do
love basketball
yeah I've never seen they do dick for
real bad yeah not a curse to love the
sport where you have the biggest
disadvantage she has the most amazing
deep brown eyes
I was like wow I'm in love
people always say I'm in love so
casually it's gross sometimes no yeah
yeah like a girl you haven't even met
you're in love 3-month you infatuated
you got passion below yeah I think
people get that rush of emotions and
that excitement about someone and they
always assume that's love and I'm like I
don't know if the hope the guy I'm in
love with no you got a boner dude I'm
now next week I'm traveling 7500 miles
all the way to the Philippines to meet
rose the love of my life
for the very first time no will I am
wearing that helmets making me nervous
because of the neck strap I'm just like
you have a safety strap or no Stivers
yeah there's not an extra he just put
that on his chin yeah
oh my god who are you how are you are
you real oh my god you're so real he was
so beautiful oh my god
I'm beyond beyond elated I'm so happy
right now I'm so very happy to see you
you promise I said say they'd invade
northern mcnair yes I am too
I couldn't find you I was so worried I'm
like I didn't think you were gonna come
because why
it's Ravi Oh traffic I'm sorry so this
is real pinch me pinch me it was just
like an out-of-body experience for me
because from three months i FaceTime
with her and now I'm standing in front
of her and I really want to kiss Rose I
really do but I want to make sure that
she really likes me am i what you
expected you like I expected yours both
on me only man who's shorter than a
Filipino woman oh yeah I see on first in
person she is really big big but short
[Laughter]
it sounds like when those nice were you
about to cry you see we the same
[Music]
little poquito coquito
oh but Daniel why is being Spanish
because the Philippines the language
they have a lot of mower that are from
Spanish do you find me attractive always
okay well well you are sorry for me what
do you think I don't want to just be
okay for you I want to be I want to be
your man your man you know you have to
know I won't care for my girl too you
know what I mean I'm high I'm okay you
just have to be okay okay I'm super
excited because I also bought a ring and
I planned to ask rose to marry me since
I met Rose I I want to look young for
her so I have been dying my hair and it
irritates my scalp so I found out that
mayonnaise makes it smoother and less
dry he's not wrong on the mayonnaise
there's mayonese for hair okay
he's pulling actual mayonnaise in it
there's such a thing as mayonnaise fair
it's actually what it is it's eggs bays
and stuff like that it knows me for your
nourishes hmm I think it's cuz I think
mayonnaise is disgusting
but it is and I put mayonnaise in my
hair mayonnaise the hair mayonnaise are
they big
if you know there's things in there that
doesn't make it smell like go skip this
clip are you gonna go to Earl yeah I
felt something coming yo so you
understand me and eggs no you know what
I mean mayonnaise before I'm okay with
it sometimes if I don't know but like
just something viscerally gross
but like clumps of mayo
last night we made love it was awesome
the kid who went on his first roller
coaster right yeah so we went on the 360
4000 it was awesome let's put it this
way I'm not only on cloud nine but I
can't wait to do it again I think she
enjoyed it but she doesn't like my beard
can I have a kiss
[Music]
really I am really we just a little
cringe so hard out of neck pain I'm
cringing so hard I can't do come time
okay here's the deal but um don't be mad
at me but um
last night when I noticed that your legs
were kind of like mine very so I'll make
your Dilek if you shave your legs I'll
shave my beard why they shave my legs
yeah I don't like leg hair
it's gross come on either thou do you
kiss me I wait for you I love you what
dancing I see what I like I know you're
tired of me asking about your past and I
don't want to do that anymore I want to
put it behind us but I have a favor
what nothing favorite so there's a test
that you can take yeah that's me
no yeah it's a it's a test for for I
know if you understand it's um STD which
is I think it's a blood test and they
just test to see if you have um like
sexually transmitted disease so that so
I was asking if you're willing to take
that test I will never ask you and
another question about your past
[Music]
disappointment
I finally understand what he said about
STD test a bill heard I feel my heart
Rock
we want to dance me I feel you're not
trust me okay
I feel offended I don't mean to offend
you but you pretty much suspect this use
of course you're feigning there it's not
just take the test it's the whole
setting I understand you would take a
test
I mean it's normal you get a new
relationship I can understand that it's
the whole set of the problem the problem
is they've been seeing each other for a
while they've already been so to ask now
sounds very disingenuous yeah exactly
now it sounds like you're accusing me of
something thank you very much cuz you
trusted me enough at the beginning yeah
we were smashing when you were talking
about loving something like that how you
gonna marry someone you don't trust
that's what I don't understand but every
time I asked you about your Facebook
friends every time I asked you about
past relationships you don't want to
talk about it
so I'm not comfortable
no I'm not
thank you very much so take this simple
test and I'll never ask you again okay
so you do you want me to take a test
yeah both of us I like her I don't know
I like this girl a lot that was petty
you do the small [ __ ] you take both of
us you date a tenth I would feel
comfortable in the States
I'll take a test but not I'm not gonna
do it here Wow
you know everything about this dude is
coming off as slimy and slimy in all
this there's like a bit of a lot of
thing there's a lot of prejudice so wait
you think it's safe for her to take that
yeah so her health her health is it's
for you no but it's her people so it's
good you know I mean that's gross yeah
I'm just I would feel more I live your
life girlfriend ya know if I take your
first it's unfair yeah I feel angry I
feel why you treat me like this
[Music]
why can't you talk about your last
relationship that's what this about
see that's what all this is about that's
what it's all about yeah cuz it didn't
make no sense it's not about the STD
yeah that's about he wants to know about
the last relationship she don't want to
talk about it yeah he really wants to
know because he's curious like that he
really wants to know yeah
[Music]
always pass me my dish
why are you always at the bus for what
what surpassed o us is past and never
come back
okay but then that's not fair to me I
[Music]
can't trust you at this point
you can't trust her because of your own
insecurities because you don't know you
have insecurities and they're flaring up
because you have details you don't know
but the reality is no amount of answers
from her are gonna swage the fact that
you're insecure about yourself why are
you dating someone you don't trust why
would you tell someone you don't trust
that you love them this is so bizarre -
because you trusted her enough to bang
her but you don't trust her enough but
it comes to your relationship I don't
understand I need some air okay
[Music]
you know your reminds me of like terms
of how he controls the situation a
little bit like a tourist Taurus is
gonna be clear what they're about to do
there maybe is gonna lie to other people
and stuff like that you know I mean but
they're gonna be clear about what
they're doing they're gonna have a good
time he's trying to being like the
witnesses oh yeah everything it looks
like it's righteous more righteous you
know say what I mean
Taurus is flesh yeah I'm not trying to
wipe you up I'm trying to you know or or
husband you up because the woman are
good with that you know shout out Cuba
and Republic Dominican I'm not trying to
wife or whatever whatever I'm just being
there you know getting you know my thing
yeah feeling my ego up this kind of like
because I'm going there with the
intention of marrying her papadum ah if
has a more like righteous way of doing
it it's like mail-order brides is that
kind of the same mentality I feel like
he's operating with the same power and
authority that a tourist has but he's
doing it under the guise of like this is
a relationship yeah you know there's
like this unfairness like don't get
tested give me my answers do this oh
this healthcare is good enough for you
my future wife but it's not good enough
for me it's a very weird dynamic I would
just say just financial privilege he
recognizes how he hovers over her in
that regard yeah
see this is crying that I don't mind you
dig what I'm saying like well sometimes
you see people crying for sympathy this
doesn't strike me as that so I actually
felt bad for her yeah yeah messed up
yeah so frustrating
because I don't think she understands
why I need to know that and I certainly
don't understand why she's hiding things
from me
[Music]
you want to talk about it
I'm on my own
it's called self-respect I like that I
like that a lot
oh you gonna treat me like this we're
done I'm gonna go home
you can pick on it Tina shocking but
dooming Baba it yes yeah Baba bhai long
didn't isne girl Pena who in opinion I'm
not gonna leave you here I want to make
sure that you get home safe how about no
I am gonna worry about you don't want
I'm sorry I'm sorry because I hurt so I
go home alone because that face goodness
she's big man a cup of brother the
Weiner brother go over long don't bother
I'm hurt like you don't know go home
alone let her do her thing cuz that big
man
you know it's what I mean so I don't
leave you're worried right now
this is gangster she's best bet for real
you hurt her in her morals you go go
home alone dude do
I bet it berry-berry hurt
it was never my intention to hurt rose
in any way but how can we begin our life
on a foundation of honesty if she she
won't be upfront with me I love her but
I still have a lot of questions I just
want to know the truth
he doesn't understand I didn't want to
hurt her she just have to understand why
I want this yeah but you have to
understand where she's coming from and
why this is hurtful to her the way some
countries are with the religions and
stuff like that you just call it you
called it off basically though it's not
if you're willing to sit down and talk
to me about your even your boyfriend
like you want Rob Jesus told you she
wants to go she's hurt and she doesn't
want to be there and you're still
talking about insecurities the lack of
understanding is impressive selfish is
very selfish I want to know I want to
know I want to know where where princess
um dad is and I'm sorry I know I'm not
gonna see spend the rest of my life with
somebody I can't trust what no who's the
father sir Prince eating my own her life
your life it's our own baby
their own wife so I never talk to her
I've never never ever and that was four
years ago
great talk to me talk to me about what
what's happened in the last four you
[Music]
hello
but I
[Music]
that's fast took a couple days and he's
doesn't believe in hitting again well
this dudes creepy as hell I don't know
the story's gonna end but we'll watch
the last couple of clips another time
that being said just from what I watched
very selfish extremely selfish very
insensitive not realizing that people
live in a different context and you can
I mean even in North America that would
be very disrespectful to ask but
especially over there what Pete said was
correct
yeah I don't know there's something very
uneasy about their dynamic and I think
it's probably because he has so much
financial privilege and she comes from
such a poor place that it kind of feels
like he's swinging his weight around a
little bit you know I mean it just feels
like yeah but I've seen that happen a
lot yeah I've seen that happen a whole
lot yeah one of my favorite countries
was kuba I've seen people acting like
that you know they got episodes on this
where people are threatened to deport
their husbands or their wives if they
don't do exactly what they're told it
feels like that absolutely it's not a
level relationship it's not 50/50 it's
really a relationship where like I got
the power the prince charming thing I
got my horse I'll save you out of this
dragon doctor ah now you owe me that's
what it feels like and if you don't do
as I'm telling you I'm gonna push you
back in that castle so I miss that's it
for today's up so we want to hear your
thoughts what do you guys think about
this and if you guys want to see us do a
part 2 be sure to just like subscribe
comment we want to hear all your
feedback and yeah don't forget we do
have a patreon page where we post our
weekly podcast so if you want more a
band preach content be sure to subscribe
there
[Music]